- You get what you wanna get.
In and out.
Don't have to wait in line.
(whooshes and squeaks)
(salsa music)
- [Host] If you don't
know what a bodega is,
then you probably haven't
lived in New York.
In Spanish, bodega
translates to grocery store.
And in New York it's the
neighborhood corner store
where you can get anything from beer
to diapers.
A new start up called Bodega,
promises he same convenience
as an actual bodega
but a lot of people
are not happy about it.
So why do we need bodegas?
(sizzles)
- But we need bodegas because
where am I gonna get my tacos?
- That's the beauty of bodegas,
you can get tacos in one place,
and something completely
different in another neighborhood.
- I've been coming to
Hajji's for, I want to say
since I was like 11.
You could come here and
get anything that you need.
Come here and get the chopped cheese
which is what I'm getting now.
Hajji's is known for it's
famous chopped cheese.
We toast it, you can get
whatever kind of cheese you like.
- So if I would make maybe 200
maybe 300 sandwiches a day.
- Get to know the people
in the neighborhood.
Get to know the people that work here,
get to know you.
- I've been working for the store
since about 20 years ago.
And I have a good customer here
and everybody love me.
- The people work here been my friend
for more than 30 years.
You say you want one beer.
You buy one beer.
You want like a plantian,
you buy one plantain.
- [Host] For many people,
bodegas feel like home,
it's about the people
and the cats.
- We got her since she was a baby.
(sizzles)
- The greatest hangover food.
- [Host] Each bodega,
depending on the neighborhood,
has something you just
can't get anywhere else.
- [Man] Those are powerful.
(dings)
- [Host] There are just some
things a machine can't replace.
- Thanks for coming, have a good day, bye.
(soft music)
(whooshes and squeaks)